Eco anxiety has been defined by the
American Psychological Association as
The Chronic fear of environmental Doom
that's Brit Ray she's an expert at the
intersection of climate change and
mental health Brit what are some ways
someone might experience climate anxiety
it can become so intense that it's
debilitating it can impair people's
functioning and then it really does need
clinical intervention or support I've
never met anybody like this I've never
encountered in the wild a person who was
actually racked with grief and fear
because of the environment I've never
had this conversation ever with anyone
where they bring up you know I'm really
troubled right now because of the um
because of the climate that's never I've
never had that now granted if anyone did
have that worry they probably wouldn't
share it with me